تحدث عن المنطقه الشماليه رغم مرور 117
يوما واشتباكات من المسافه صفر في المناطق
الشماليه من قطاع غزه رغم الانسحابات
واعاده التموضع الاسرائيلي في المناطق
الشماليه عندما نتحدث عن المناطق الشماليه
فنحن بطبيعه الحال او بتركيز اكثر نتحدث
عن المناطق الجنوبيه الغربيه من مدينه غزه
اذ يتمركز الجيش الاسرائيلي في هذه
المنطقه بعد ان نفذ مجموعه من عمليات
الانسحاب لكنه بقي متمركزا في المنطقه
الجنوبيه من مدينه غزه وتحديدا حي الزيتون
اطراف جحر الديك والمنطقه الجنوبيه
الغربيه منطقه الشيخ عجلين وتل الهواء
اليوم كتاب القسام اعلنت سبعه عن عن سبعه
عمليات سته منها كانت في المنطقه الجنوبيه
الغربيه وتحديدا في منطقه تل الهواء تزامن
هذا هذه الاعلانات تزامنت مع اعلان الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن خوضه معارك عنيفه في هذه
المنطقه ومقتل ضابطين وجنديين واصابه عشره
احد هؤلاء الضباط من وحده تش الداغ وهي
وحده متخصصه في جمع المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه قتل هذا الضابط وفق
المعلومات وف تطابق المعلومات بين روايه
الجيش الاسرائيلي وروايه القسام الذي قال
انه قنص ضابطا في هذه المنطقه فان الضابط
قتل في معارك تل الهواء عندما نتحدث عن تل
الهواء فنحن نتحدث عن منطقه بهذا الشكل
تقريبا منطقه لا تتجاوز مساحتها حوالي اقل
من 3 م مربع تقع تقع في المنطقه الجنوبيه
الغربيه من مدينه غزه تعرضت لقصف عنيف
خلال الاسابيع القليله الماضيه ل الاحتلال
كما ذكرنا تمركز في هذه المناطق الجنوبيه
وتحديدا في منطقه شارع عشره الذي نشاهده
على الشاشه بعد ان نفذت قوات الاحتلال
عمليات الانسحاب من اطراف من الاطراف
الغربيه لمدينه غزه نفذت هذه العمليه
وتمركزت بمحاذاه شارع 10 ومن شارع 10 بدات
عملياتها في التوغل والتراجع نحو المناطق
الجنوبيه الغربيه من مدينه غزه وتحديدا
منطقه تل الهواء بالتزامن مع القصف العنيف
الذي الذي تعرضت له تل اله والتدمير
الكبير في هذه المنطقه تدخل القوات
الاسرائيليه لتنفذ عمليات مناوره في هذه
المنطقه في منطقه تل الهواء واليوم كما
شاهدنا مقطع الفيديو الذي نشرته كتاب
القسام واعلانات كتاب القسام وايضا
اعلانات سرايا القدس التي ذكرت ايضا انها
تخوض اشتباكات في تل الهواء والصبره في
المنطقه الجنوبيه والجنوبيه الغربيه من
مدينه غزه هذا يعني ان هذا المحور عاد
للتحرك من جديد مع ضغط قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مره اخرى من الجهه الجنوبيه
لمدينه غزه ودائما الهدف وفق ما يمكن
قراءته الهدف دائما هوقلب مدينه غزه
والبلده القديمه مدينه غزه الذي لم تتمكن
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من الدخول الى
هذه النقطه رغم توغلها من المنطقه الشرقيه
من منطقه الشجاعيه توغلها من المنطقه
الشماليه والشماليه الغربيه منطقه الشيخ
رضوان ومنطقه حتى منطقه جباليه البلد
لكنها لم تتمكن من دخول قلب مدينه غزه او
البلده القديمه المحاذيه لشارع صلاح الدين
اذا هذا تطور نوعي لافه النظر خلال
الساعات ال 24 الماضي ان تعود تل الهواء
وتعود المنطقه الشماليه من قطاع غزه
لواجهه الاحداث والاشتباكات من مسافه صفر
لكن هذا الامر لا يعني ان المناطق الاخرى
لم تكن فيها اشتباكات المنطقه الجنوبيه
بطبيعه الحال خانيونس التركيز الكبير
عليها سرايا القدس كانت الصاحبه نصيب
الاسد اليوم في عمليات المقاوم في المنطقه
الجنوبيه وتحديدا خان يونس اعلنت السرايا
بانها نفذت مجموعه من عمليات الاستهداف
وتحديدا في المنطقه الغربيه والشماليه
الغربيه والجنوبيه الغربيه من خان يونس
هذا القاطع الذي نشاهده على الشاشه تضغط
قوات الاحتلال بشكل كبير من هذا القاطع
باتجاه قلب مدينه خانيونس عمليات تدمير
ممنهج في هذه المنطقه من جهه معسكر او
مخيم خانيونس في المنطقه الغربيه من
المدينه ومن الجهه الجنوبيه الغربيه ومن
جهه الشماليه الغربيه لخان يونس اذا ما
دخلنا بصوره اقرب الى هذذه المنطقه فنحن
نشاهد مخيم خان يونس الذي تنفذ فيه قوات
الاحتلال عمليات قصف ممنهج في هذه المنطقه
المنطقه الشمال الغربيه ونتحدث عن منطقه
الصناعه وما حولها وتضغط قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بهذا الشكل لتدخل الى قلب
مدينه خان يونس وتحديدا منطقه مستشفيي
النصر الناصر والامل لانها تعتبر ان هذه
المنطقه هي منطقه قلب المدينه وقلب عمليات
العسكريه والاداره العمليات العسكريه
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه في المنطقه الجنوب في
منطقه خان يونس